yeah welcome to a new game against
internal med international marseille
from from Spain fonso fan jay and we get
the Bronstein laws again they didn't
play the the early c3 but Knight f3
wants to exchange him yeah why not why
not actually ok maybe a 94 problem was
playing very quickly but I don't
understand anyway how people use the
time they very often place so quickly
that I don't understand that or what
they're doing came yeah frf for before I
was threatening it for me without really
noticing it this is why I played queen
of three all right so what are we doing
now hmm of course ahead it already looks
like black shouldn't have any big
problems the the issue is how to
continue maybe 24 queen for looks likely
interesting getting a pawn to e4 even
but of course I can also just just a
castle maybe place g4 if I cancel I
better but I can play a 4 against this
not clear ok let's let's castle first g4
I've f4 I am if he takes Queen of 6 wins
what
why not Queen f6 I thought this wins
apiece
hmm did I overlooked something wow it
just winds a peaceful okay yeah I
thought you would retreat and then I
play h5 and I know it's it's complicated
should be okay for black but nothing
special I don't see a way to rescue the
peace now white resigns yo yeah he must
go just to d2 and not much happening I
mean it's interesting age five and I
thought this might be might be quite
quite okay I mean I can't can't really
be Rossi as black good if anything the
more active position may be here this
night also doesn't do much at the moment
and maybe I can even play here and
intensify the pressure yeah the computer
already gives me a pretty distinct
advantage but okay yeah it's not the way
to to combat this line really it's a
very very weak to have this this kind of
setup here it's you can do it but it's
no no advantage door for what yeah okay
bit of a bit of an opening disaster here
thanks for watching